your daughter must be is she excited
about this she well she's very excited
because the episode that I did it's a
character that I did a couple seasons
ago and they brought the character back
and then they wrote a new episode for
the character where he is dating and and
wants to marry this other Pony
who has a daughter and I guess the pony
went through the Ponyville version of
divorce I don't know how they divorced
and yeah Pony land but so they went when
they brought mething oh hey would your
cuz my wife Meredith Sandra is an
actress and does a lot of voiceover they
go would your wife Meredith and would
your daughter like to voice these two
characters also no the three of us went
in and recorded it together and we put
Alice had her little headphones on and
was doing her character and we were like
you know getting her it was really
amazing to see her like do these scenes
and go I need to do this like like even
she got into the whole acting bug thing
of like like I can do that better let me
do this again and like trying to write
so that was so now she is going to make
her little sweet heard a little
voiceover debut you know what I have
that's very sweet
the one thing I have found I have two
children they're older now but whenever
they would get interested in a really
loved a cartoon in that invariably word
would maybe get back to those people
that oak Owens family watches his
cartoon and then they would come to me
and they would say Conan do you want to
be a voice on this cartoon and my kids
would be like you've got to do it you've
got to do it you've got to do it so be
like alright business schedule but I'll
go in and I'll be one of the voices of
mr. Bibble Babylon the doubly lovely and
yeah and so what happens is animation
takes a long time by the time it comes
out yeah kids guess what I'm on the dip
with tabla showing they're like good
show
[Applause]
yeah - like you know why would you do
that shave you know exactly I can't why
look I got my kids this week and I got
time to watch that but yeah I'm going to
vets meetings yeah whatever I mean she
was very excited to go into it I mean
yes she had to mean she had outgrown my
little pony a little bit at the time but
it was still exciting for her too to go
in and do it but now of course you know
she's into like Harry Potter and
spider-man but again yeah by the time if
I ever got asked to do that she would
probably outgrow that yes well she was
still very it still meant a lot to her
to be like wow I'm actually cuz then
they also sent her a drawing of her
characters he's like I must bring this
to life you know so no yeah she's insane
yeah it was weird when she went she
really gets into the act even if he
turns into like a 42 year old German mad
scientist